là où j'ai vu dépasser
à son actif c'est avec l'eau parce qu'il
s'est mis à l'essai à 6 seulement
pensent et tenez la ctn et il disait à
celui qui perd ses blondes de conduire
ne pas s'arrêter ils ont enlevé le
magnat
nous ont
ligoté sur le sommet mais mon père ils
ont commencé les petits j'étais ici
l'aubaine
et actionnez l'interrupteur
cité lui le mentionnait le responsable
c'était jean marie le pen c'est une cité
le chef des pensionnaires à fond jean
paul city lui c'est comme ça qu'on je
suis omniprésent il était partout il
était aux fourneaux prat il était à la
villa des saisines et il était à la
villa des fleurs il était habile qu il
était à la casbah il était partout c'est
le diable c'est absolument oui c'est ça
alger 2007
je débarque dans la ville blanche ou
depuis 50 ans des voix s'élèvent pour
accusé jean marie le pen de torture
pendant la guerre d'algérie
les voix de plusieurs moudjahidine
les anciens combattants de la guerre
d'indépendance
alors je décide de partir à la rencontre
de ces hommes du moins ceux qui sont
encore vivants pour tenter de savoir ce
qui s'est réellement passé ici il y à un
demi-siècle
l'algérie fait encore partie de la
france mais depuis trois ans c'est la
guerre
les algériens veulent leur indépendance
mais pour la france pas question de
perdre ses trois départements d'afrique
du nord
quatre cent mille soldats français du
contingent sont envoyés combattre les
rebelles indépendantistes du fln le
front de libération nationale
c'est une guerre qui ne dit pas son nom
on parle pudiquement d'opérations de
maintien de l'ordre mais c'est un
conflit long cruel et douloureux qui
fera plusieurs centaines de milliers de
morts
sur le terrain un engagé volontaire de
27 ans qui sert dans le prestigieux
régiment parachutiste du 1er rep jean
marie le pen
je viens d'être élu député en janvier 56
et avec mon collègue de marques et qui
est de lui-même comme moi un ancien ados
chine nous décidons de nous engager pour
une période de six mois
pour tout d'abord pour montrer notre
solidarité avec les jeunes qui sont
envoyés en algérie dans le cadre du
contingent et aussi pour aller voir tout
de même sur le terrain ce qui s'y passe
parce que je suis aussi algérie
française c'est à dire je crois à la
nécessité de garder l'algérie dans la
france mais je j'ai aussi une certaine
angoisse de voir le développement d'une
action qui n'est pas seulement interne
mais qui est aussi extérieure et il y à
des puissances étrangères qui ne sont
pas du tout d'accord pour que la france
reste en algérie surtout depuis qu'elle
a découvert du pétrole au sahara
depuis janvier 1956 jean marie le pen
est député il a été élu sur les listes
du mouvement populiste et anti
républicain de pierre poujade
c'est aussi un colonialiste convaincus
qu'ils n'hésitent pas à prendre les
armes pour défendre ses idées deux ans
plus tôt il s'est engagé comme
lieutenant pendant la guerre d'indochine
pour le lieutenant députés le pen c'est
aujourd'hui en algérie que l' empire
colonial français est menacé
quand il débarque que le 28 décembre
1956 c'est le début de la bataille
d'alger
en réponse à un attentat sanglant de
partisans de l'algérie française les
indépendantistes du fln poste à leur
tour des bombes dans des cafés et des
restaurants fréquentés par les européens
[Musique]
le pouvoir politique confié alors les
pleins pouvoirs à l'armée
c'est désormais la 10e division
parachutiste du général massu qui
administre la ville
sa mission kc l'insurrection algéroise
et démanteler les réseaux a fait l'aisne
à n'importe quel prix
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
sont arrêtées entre 3 et 4000 vont
disparaître corps et biens et beaucoup
seront torturés
la bataille d'alger la singularité c'est
qu'effectivement il y avait sept 7 ce
contexte disons de d'urgence sur le
problème des bombes dans la ville et qui
fait qu'effectivement la
l'utilisation de la torture a été
massive rapide et généralisée serre que
c'est la singularité aussi du contexte
historique sans vouloir justifier bien
entendu c'est à dire que là on a
effectivement une pratique qui s'érige
en système de manière systématique à
partir de ce moment là dans un contexte
encore une fois bien précis qui est
celui de
du terrorisme contre des civils
européens
pour lutter contre le terrorisme et
anéantir le fln les descentes de parra
se multiplient de jour comme de nuit
un climat de terreur s'installe en
particulier dans la casbah le coeur
historique d'alger où habite la
population musulmane
zambito ou 33 une fiche à la casbah
c'était le l'ennui du 2 ou 3
philippe minuit
on était à la maison en train de dormir
tel qu'on en attendait
rapporte qu'elle explosait
et
un groupe de militaires a fait rentrer
qu écrire les deux bouts de boue en
insultant
une feuille et rentrer dans les chambres
et neuf en sortir tout le monde doit
tout le monde dehors
mustapha merouane avait 20 en 1957
c'était l'un des nombreux messages et du
fln il témoigne des tortures qu'il a
subies dans la maison familiale en même
temps que son père
y adhérer sur le temps avec le bétail
est qui nous surveillait j'étais droit
et de temps à la maison j'étais euros
avec des femmes
y'a rien mais quand il arrive le pilote
qu'on mange il commence et arnaud
tentures et et les féliciter branché il
était branché à la paix une prise je
suis pas en bas avec l'interrupteur et
procédés acteurs au son bien ouais le
tas s'est
déclenchée donc le pen lui il déclaré si
le pack est déclenché et oui si le pack
est déclenché il déclencher le pen mais
quand je parlais quelque chose en pire
arrêté et produit des notes c'est lui
qui prenait des personnes avaient fait
après recommencer recommencer
trois quarts d'heure quand magnitude et
la paire pas écouté ses opérations
d'interrogatoire dans dans l'aude dans
l'appartement de la personne en question
mais c'est invraisemblable monsieur le
pain tout de même vous savez très bien
qu'il y avait des tortures qui avait
lieu à domicile à cette époque là
mondiale non non j'ai rien du tout tout
ça donc pas du tout et même changez rien
vous dites il aurait été mon jeu non moi
je n'ai jamais été au courant jamais été
au courant d'interrogatoire qui est eu
lieu dans les dents dans l'aide dans les
domiciles des gens cherchent et jamais
les interrogatoires à domicile était
pourtant fréquents les centres de
torture étaient débordés et il fallait
faire parler les suspects avant que le
fln des temps de réagir
de la rapidité dépend de l'efficacité et
les troupes du général massu n'avait de
comptes à rendre à personne
lorsque jean marie le pen et alger en
janvier février mars 1957 il n'ya pas
encore cette volonté du contrôle
politique qui va s'exercer par la suite
à partir d'avril mai 1957 où
effectivement devant l'effervescence
l'émotion suscitée par des publications
de témoignages comme celui
servan-schreiber comme la démission du
général de bollardière et ces bons qui
protestaient contre l'utilisation de la
torture en algérie qu'à ce moment là le
pouvoir politique va essayer de
reprendre en main donc envoyé des
commission denquête de savoir ce qui se
passe etc mais entre janvier février
mars pendant ces trois mois là ces
cartes blanches données disons à
certaines unités de l'armée c'est
évident
carte blanche à paris le gouvernement
dirigé par le socialiste guy mollet se
défend pourtant de toute exaction de la
part de l'armée en algérie
s'il était vrai qu'il y ait des
brutalités organisé par un individu ou
deux
le calme rétabli donc
dans les 2 jours 3 jours qui suivent une
arrestation que pour faire parler un
coupable soit torturé ce serait
intolérable
c'est pas quand cela même si ça ne se
produit qu'une fois il ya des méthodes
que les autres emplois qu aux
adversaires emploi mais même dans ce cas
là on n'a pas de mal à répondre par la
méthode la france et c'est dans le pays
des droits de l'homme
ouvert par le pouvoir politique
les militaires ont les mains libres pour
continuer les arrestations et les
interrogatoires musclés
le jaune mois le demande matin il y
avait deux jeunes parents qu'ils ont
ouvrir la peau de jonas hiller
l'important faire ils m'ont appelée
abdellaoui mois m j'ai dit c'est moi un
départ et mardi abdellaoui
monsieur le typique et appelle à
l'assemblée monsieur keep it à mon
époque c'est pas que ça veut dire je
savais pas bon et même les départs à
montréal hier dans ses chambres dans les
chambres
j'étais juré le pen a6 a6a bien aux
parents ils étaient bien costaud il
était tout blanc il m'a dit qu'est ce
que tu que je te connais des fins autres
que monsieur moi je lui dis monsieur moi
je connais rien de ferme aussi un
travailleur tué un travailleur avait il
relevé 20 mois de dos alors qu'est ce
qu'il m'a dit il m'a dit moi aussi j'y
travaille demandez à poil moder poids
tournée j'ai enlevé tous tous mes
habitués aux tournées et la paix et a
appelé les deux parents il m'a et harry
côté marc côté les mains les pieds on
m'a mis par terre il y avait un sac un
sac vite que tout - tous - tout mouillé
puis ils ont joué et avait un défi des
fils électriques
j'avais un feeling tic dans le sexe le
deuxième fils dans le pays dans l'autre
de pied droit et après joueurs
jean-marie peine a ajouté un des totors
tout le monde
[Musique]
faure l'empereur sur les hauteurs
d'alger un des lieux où les suspects
tête interrogé par les militaires
français
mohamed abdellaoui avait 27 ans en 1957
il était militant du fln pour lequel il
distribuera des tracts aux clandestins
cinquante ans après il revient pour la
première fois dans ce fort où il resta
enfermé pendant plus d'un mois
[Musique]
c'est ici je me rappelle c'était ici une
table une chaise devant le revenant jean
marie le pen terrifié
c'est que le tableau de la torture
ici les torturer ici par terre
non c'est totalement faux ça c'est
totalement faux je ne sais même pas où
se trouve ce ce fort l'empereur alors on
torturait d'où donc que j'ai à domicile
dans les unités
dans l'est comment dirais-je dans les
états-majors
de bataillon de de riz est aussi dans
l'effort notamment ce fameux font preuve
je lui dis tu es moi ça jure
tuez-moi pas comme disait traqué mois le
pain qu est-ce qu il m'aider et me tiens
comme ça par la tête par les cheveux il
me colle la tête
dans le cadrage compliqué mais c'est
comme çà comme çà comme çà comme çà
comme çà et je me suis venu plusieurs
fois sur tout l'effectif tant le sexe
mon dieu c'était horrible horrible
de voir le site est horrible vraiment
aux héroïnes moi je suis lieutenant je
commande une section
je suis
avec le kop le capitaine martin qui
commande la compagnie alors là nous
faisons toutes les missions qui sont
affectés à la division c'est à dire
contrôles d'identité arrestations
perquisitions
barrage à toutes ces choses là qui sont
les l'opération général de
2,2 comment dirais-je de neutralisation
de l'appareil et demi est ce que vous
participez aux interrogatoires également
non pas aux interrogatoires papa aux
interrogatoires spécialisé si vous
voulez bien sûr je demande aux gens leur
état civil lors ces choses-là leur
travail où il travaille qu'est ce qu'ils
font ou ils étaient at elle voit la part
des interrogatoires poussés pas
d'interrogatoire violent non ce n'est
pas par djamel non
pourtant d'autres témoins encore dit se
souvenir des interrogatoires du
lieutenant le pen même quand ils
utilisaient un surnom comme le faisait
souvent les militaires en opérations à
l'époque
abdelkader amour avait 19 ans en 1957 il
était secrétaire d'une cellule du fln de
la casbah il témoigne lui aussi des
tortures qu'il a subies dans la maison
où il habitait avec ses parents
il y avait quelqu'un blanc bon c'est
qu'ils étaient
faux bleu un pull sanguinaire
quand champs quand il parle c'est
vraiment vers la haine
et on l'appeler mal marco luttes nos mac
os mac os mac os
mais c'était lui le plus il avait une
équipe certainement aussi entonné que
lui dans la domaine
et
moi j'étais persuadé à ce moment là dès
que je vais je le déciderai il n'est pas
venu pour les uns parce qu'il n'en
existait pas tellement plus en mai
évoluer nous casser vraiment nos baisers
dans sa tête c'est tellement ils
devaient se dire que cela ceux qui ont
osé se soulever contre nous et c'est bon
c'est déjà qu'il faut matin il faut
détruire voilà quelqu'un était assez sur
ce thème alcoa lâchait pas pour lui et
c'est assez sur mon banquier
quasi en même temps les mêmes et ça j'ai
eu mon départ continent de plus contre
mais est versée d'euros il ya en lui
tenait le soutien à quelqu'un qui
berçait d'euros alors quand il s'arrête
un peu et voir je mets tout vous dire
allez vas-y continue est atteint voilà
voilà la nuit
marco la nuit de marc emery bon
ce macross
ce personnage
une personnage parce que maman c'est
la découverte de quelques jours a
rappelé que c'était le pen depuis qu'une
opel comme on l'appelait quand est-ce
que vous avez su le nom de le pen chez
en regardant le journal
un programme
pour lequel elle s'était alors oui c'est
un camp d'internement à un camp de
concentration oui vous avez été après
oui après les tankers
semblé en
progrès et alors là on joue bien on
était dans la grille tombe parce
qu'avant city doit guider guitton il ya
bien prisonnier qui est venu d'y revenir
car tu es venu quand il faut faire des
loopings si le pen sa peine de peindre
le cadet de l'équipe qui m'a torturé et
habite aujourd'hui chez lui lui oui tout
le monde dans le conduit tout le monde a
reconnu ça c'est la photo où il est
décoré sur wii
vous regardez cette photo et vous verrez
bien si je suis reconnaissable je
voulais montrer cette fois vu mais oui
vous les achetez une boulette mais je ne
suis pas reconnaissable sincèrement et
pourquoi donc parce que regarde on
l'avouera ensemble et vous verrez que
c'est le cas non c'est pas possible
voilà encore une fois les gens qui ont
été arrêtés dans les différents secteurs
ont et qu'ils sont libres
doivent justifier auprès de leurs amis
du fln d'être en liberté et doivent bien
sûr trouver une raison soit de dire
qu'ils sont évadés soin de dire qu'ils
ont été torturés est petit ça
de toute façon jean marie le pen n'aime
pas beaucoup ce mot de torture
qu'est ce que veut dire la tendance on
en revient à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure de l'eau de l'électricité sont
les miens de coercition à l'asie voilà
beaucoup plus d'ailleurs à mon avis
intimidant que réelle voilà écoutez je
peux vous dire que les gens que j'ai
interrogés ça avait l'air assez réelle
tout de même ce qu'on leur a fait oui
on l'aura moi j'ai entendu en fin de
parole de la deuxième guerre mondiale
j'ai entendu parler de gens dont on
avait arraché les ongles arrachés les
dents fait des choses comme ça je crois
pas que vous allez y ai trouvé des comme
ça ce n'était pas ça en effet c'était le
supplice de l'eau c'est chaud et
l'électricité à très bon j'ai des choses
qui ne laisse pas de traces branché sur
le secteur tout à fait des choses qui ne
s'est pas cassé salement des choses qui
ne laisse pas de trace ni qui n'ont pas
de conséquences physiologiques ni
données ni de des traumatismes posters
hier voilà sur le moment ça fait mal
mais après c'est fini voilà bah oui ça
fait moins mal qu'une bombe qui vous
arracher une jambe mais enfin
mais les terroristes sont très
pointilleux sur leurs droits et sur leur
intégrité physique
là faut pas rigoler un garde auraient
même cassé un mois il paraît alors les
noms un faux pas présenté en revanche
leur bombe faisait pas le détail
près elle est fausse et je vous dis j'ai
eu aucune considération pour ce genre de
d'habitation d'accusation de déclaration
si vous avez demandé monsieur le pen
vous de torture et vous l'auriez fait si
si la vessie cette manière de ferme
quand une fois je n'aime pas votre mot
qui est trop ambigu si j'avais dû forcer
par la violence des terroristes à
m'avouer où étaient leurs bombes je
crois que je l'aurais fait oui
les faits sans scrupules estimant que
mon devoir de protéger la population
civile et de sauver les vies humaines
d'usiné sang des innocents était très
supérieure au devoir de respect de la
ddt de d'un détenu criminelle
[Musique]
ce
mais la torture ne servait pas seulement
à débusquer des bombes dans une guerre
contre des terroristes
c'était aussi un instrument destiné à
terroriser l'ensemble d'une population
musulmane prête à se soulever et des
milliers d'algériens en sont membres
un quatrième témoins accusent
précisément jean marie le pen de la mort
d'un homme
mohamed moulay avait 12 en 1957 quand il
a assisté au supplice de son père
militant du fln lui aussi dans la maison
familiale de la casbah
sent bon entreprise devenue une langue
or là on lui marche et du coup de pied
sur les côtés sur le ventre il essaye de
se relever avec difficulté un coup sur
la figure enfin je ne trouve pas les
mots pour décrire ce qu'ils publient
en fait s'il a les deux magasins comme
mon père précédée il était artisan
électricien
et
de la maison de là pour la maison
habilité on l'avait
en effet un fait la première fois partie
la première sciences d'une structure
palau on l'a ramené pour lui faire
bénéficier
ce soit si on à rome le tremblement des
véhicules étaient mouillés trompé et
puis là
la pause la terre et on a branché on à
moi je fais des fils électriques nous
avons entendu des cris lieu la nuit des
cris des hurlements dessus des douleurs
surtout gémissements et
assez longtemps quand même ce matin et
est un moment c'était le silence total
complet donc nous avons
d'abord eu cette intuition qui étaient
déjà morts parce qu'un point de plus ces
gisements j'ai
écrit chez
s'est éteint de secours
après la mort de son père le jeune
mohamed moulay va ramasser dans l'entrée
de la maison familiale ce qui va devenir
une pièce à conviction dans le dossier
le pen
or là c'est ici que j'ai retrouvé le
lendemain au petit matin un ceinture en
toile kaki sur lequel était accroché un
poignard un preneur dans son fourreau
je savais qu'il appartenait aux
militaires donc j'avais pris et j'avais
posé directement j'ai caché dans
ce truc de quais chant qui protège le
compteur électrique voilà
c'est le fameux brogniart ou
propriétés à christ est gravé le nom de
jm le pen 1er rep
jm le pen 1er rep le 1er régiment
étranger de parachutistes auquel
appartenait jean marie le pen lors de
son séjour à alger
gravé sur un couteau du mouvement des
jeunesses hitlériennes la hitler jugend
et bien j'aurais perdu mon ceinturon
a perdu mon ceinturon ça diront auquel
normalement est attaché mon revolver et
mon poignard or au lieu d'un poignard de
parachutistes qui la remet en quelque
sorte
légales et réglementaires qui est un
poignard baïonnette d'ailleurs quand moi
je la fantaisie morts et poussé à avoir
un poignard de hyper your gun
c'est vrai que la grogne de la croix
gammée manqué dans tout ça alors c'est
un petit poignard ce que les eagles et
les scouts qui ne fait rien c'est un
petit bruit c'est sa cdc auquel
appartenait d'ailleurs même le pape
ouvriers bon ces débris scouts et ils
ont des petits un petit poignard comme
ça de avec une petite lame et c'est le
lieutenant le pen lui il aura mais la
fantaisie au lieu d'avoir son première
de combat eh bien il avait ce petit
poignard d'été à young guns à sa
ceinture ça fait rire tout le monde ça
fait rire tout le monde y compris des
adversaires politiques pour peu qu'ils
connaissent l'armée et ses traditions
pardonnez moi mais il paraît enfin
certains disent que c'était répondu à
l'époque dans la légion et que du fait
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'anciens soldats
de la wehrmacht dans la légion il y
avait toujours ses petits couteaux qui
était une espèce de comment dire de
blagues à kruth et elsa voyez ça alors
c'est la première fois de ma vie que
j'entends dire ça n'avait jamais comme
quoi les les légendes peuvent naître
de rien contre mon père a été tué ces
mêmes paroles sont revenus deux nuits de
suite en fouillant toute la maison ils
n'ont pas dit ce qu'il cherchait met en
doute et qui cherchait quelque chose de
très important et c'était en fait
c'était le couteau qui cherchait
alors j'ai
fouillé toute la maison de fond en
comble son pouvoir gens renversés les
légumes et
les armoires les tiroirs et cetera mais
sans pouvoir trouver quoi que ce soit
le 31 mars 1957 le général massu des
corps le lieutenant le pen de la croix
de la valeur militaire
il a fini la période de six mois pour
laquelle il s'était engagé la guerre
continue sans lui il rentre à paris où
il va reprendre ses habits de député
[Musique]
dans la capitale on commence à critiquer
les méthodes de l'armée
de retour d'algérie où il était
lieutenant comme le pen le journaliste
jean-jacques servan-schreiber raconte sa
guerre dans l'express
et au sommet de la hiérarchie militaire
le général de bollardière est condamné à
60 jours de prison pour avoir dénoncé la
torture
jean marie le pen lui va s'en faire le
défenseur le 30 mai le journal le monde
rapporte des propos qu'il a tenus avec
son camarade de marquer au cercle
républicain
nous avons reçu une mission de police et
nous l'avons accompli selon un impératif
d'efficacité qui exige des moyens
illégaux
la torture est inévitable et donc dans
les conditions anormales où l'on nous
demande d'agir elle est juste
j'ai dit cela pourquoi parce que la
grande muette ne pouvait pas s'exprimer
et les insulter elles étaient dix femmes
et sans pouvoir se défendre
je fais les militaires n'ont pas droit à
la parole à moi j'aime bien mais j'avais
la chance d'avoir été d'être un
militaire qui se retrouvaient dans le
civil et en plus de ça qui disposait
d'une certaine audience politique alors
je me suis assimilés j'ai dit nous nous
nous nous là l'armée française nous nous
les
les officiers français voient la weed en
utilisent des méthodes illégales pour
lutter contre des méthodes illégales
mais moins beaucoup moins terrible est
beaucoup moins terrifiante
que celle utilisée par nos adversaires
un mois plus tard à la tribune de
l'assemblée le député le pen déclare
j'étais à alger officier de
renseignement à la 10e division
aéroportée et comme tel je dois être aux
yeux d'un certain nombre de nos
collègues ce que pourrait être le
mélange d'un officier ss et d'un agent
de la gestapo ce métier je les fais
c'est le métier de la recherche du
terrorisme dans alger et c'est le métier
font tous les officiers de monde mais
unité de la division aéroportée voilà
c'est l'accusation pèse collectivement
sur nous touche d'ailleurs moi je n'ai
jamais été ciblés
ben voyons il ya eu des commissions d
enquête
il ya eu des commissions nationales
s'est jamais été cité à aucun moment je
n'ai jamais été citée que dans la presse
politique ennemis ou dans la presse
algérienne
révolutionnaires et terroristes
pratiquants ddd des atrocités son nom
mais seulement pendant 50 ans aussi bien
dans la guerre contre la france que dans
la guerre qu'ils ont fait en guerre
civile entre eux d'accord mais là on est
à la tribune de l'assemblée nationale
française à la tribune de l'assemblée je
parle de la représentation nationale
il me semble que je ne crains pas
d'exposé de problème puisque je suis là
devant tous les députés français y
compris la majorité de gauche tout à
fait enfin voyons et vous dites
je les fais écouter monsieur c'est en
fait à l'interrogatoire de police mais
vous avez dit ça monsieur c'est sûr
qu'on ne risque que tu es sérieux donc
danser à ce moment là c'était laid c'est
une chose qui n'est pas du tout clair
maintenant vos biographie c'est que vous
dit devant l'assemblée nationale
officier de renseignement j'étais
officier des pages et des pages et c'est
ça ne
s'était pas officier de renseignement ce
métier est ce les métiers l'âge je les
laisse je faisais ce métier comme tous
les autres nous étions en situation
d'être des officiers de renseignement
puisque nous étions lutte contre ces
très graves séquelles une fonction très
précises officiellement mais bien sûr et
vous pouvez me pillay et la suze 50 ans
après d'accord voilà j'aimerai
mars 1962 c'est le cessez le feu la
guerre est finie elle a fait plus de dix
mille morts côté français et plus de
500000 côté algérien
les accords d'evian sont signés et des
décrets d'amnisty sont immédiatement
promulguer
ces décrets interdisent les poursuites
contre les auteurs de violences en
france comme en algérie
les victimes ne pourront jamais attaqué
leur bourreau en justice il n'y aura
donc jamais d'en quête sur les tortures
et les meurtres de l'armée française ni
sur les attentats et les crimes du fln
dès juin 1962 pourtant dans son journal
vérité liberté
l'historien pierre vidal-naquet met en
cause jean marie le pen il y publie un
rapport de police de 1957 signé du
commissaire principal gil
c'est la déposition d'un algérien qui
accuse nommément jean marie le pen de
l'avoir torturée
deux fils électriques furent reliés aux
lobes de ses oreilles et le lieutenant
le pen lui même faisait fonctionner une
magnéto à manivelle à l'aide de laquelle
il eut envoyé des décharges électriques
dans le corps
ce commissaire gilles diehl j'ai connu
quelqu'un qui a dit qu'ils avaient dit
qu'il y avait dit qu'elle eut déposé
chez moi à la police et ça moi je
connais quelqu'un c'est ça c'est un truc
de ravitaillement après le reconnaissez
tout de même que la république est quand
même bonne fille parce qu'en pleine
période de terrorisme algérien
à monsieur qui avait été victime de
sévices
éventuelle de l'armée pouvait aller à la
police pour porter plainte
c'est pas exactement là le climat dont
on disait que quelques secondes il que
de climat qui régnait en algérie à ce
moment là pas tout à fait
les militants du fln torturé par l'armée
en 1957 ne portait pas plainte c'est un
fait mais abdennour yahiaoui lui n'a pas
hésité car il n'est pas effet laine
comme le souligne le rapport du
commissaire gilles sa famille est très
honorablement connus et manifeste des
sentiments nettement pro français
quelques mois plus tard dans le journal
combat le député le pen donne une
interview dans laquelle il persiste et
signe
il déclare je n'ai rien à cacher j'ai
torturé parce qu'il fallait le faire
[Musique]
je continue d'en rire maintenant et que
cette question mon interrogatoire de
police comme vous dites il ya ce fameux
article de 62 dans combat
clarté guéant robin hood a écrit lomé où
il a créé de laine noir sur blanc j'ai
torturé il a été démentie quarante huit
heures après ça a été gelée démenti
voilà c c et c'est ici si vous posez
d'avoir pas exister puisque je les
démentis d'accord quelqu'un dit que
j'avais 17 ans j'ai dit non j'ai pas dit
ça nul et non avenu donc voilà
nulle et non avenue pas vraiment car le
démenti de jean marie le pen est en fait
une mise au point dans laquelle il joue
à nouveau sur la définition du mot
torture les méthodes de contraintes
utilisé pour démanteler les réseaux
effet laine non dans les unités que j'ai
connu jamais pu être assimilés à des
tortures et il en justifie encore une
fois usage en parlant de légitime
défense
quatre ans plus tard le 4 octobre 1966
l'ancien maire d'alger ancien ministre
de la défense nationale jacques
chevalier accuse à son tour jean marie
le pen d'avoir torturé un de ses
employés de mairie
à l'époque le pen ne réagit pas mais ils
crient aujourd'hui au complot
ce sont des adversaires politiques
ce sont des ennemis politiques dans une
guerre révolutionnaire où le sang coule
le
[Musique]
1972 jean marie le pen fonde le front
national avec une poignée de fidèles
c'est l'époque où il porte un bandeau
contrairement à certaines rumeurs ce
n'est pas en algérie qu'il a perdu un
oeil dix ans plus tard le fn enregistre
ses premiers succès électoraux aux
municipales de 1983
le pen s'impose définitivement sur la
scène politique nationale
le 13 février 1984 il est invité pour la
première fois à l'émission politique
vedette l'heure de vérité on lui reparle
à lors du fameux rapport gilles ce
rapport déclare c'était le commissaire
principal gil que lors de l'arrestation
d'un algérien yahiaoui abdennour lors de
son arrestation deux fils électriques
sur relie au lob de ses oreilles et le
lieutenant le pen lui même faisait
fonctionner une magnéto à manivelle à
l'aide de laquelle il lui envoyait des
décharges électriques dans le corps je
vous passe le reste le narrateur c'est
scandaleux bon ok ce général ce monsieur
gilles n'a jamais témoigné de cela ou at
il témoigné de cela j'ai été copie de ce
scandaleux c'est là une provocation
policière c'est une provocation
policière aménagé elle salue même plié
été publié et publier deux reprises
premièrement 1962 dans un journal qui
s'appelle vérité liberté au monde le
sida de l'oréal dépité tortionnaires
révélé cayenne informations sur la
guerre d'algérie dirigée par un homme
qui a une réputation at elle et monsieur
pierre vidal naquet oh mon dieu et ce
journal n'a jamais été n'a jamais été
attaqué par mais encore une fois le fait
de ne pas attaquer une diffamation ou un
mensonge ne constitue pas pour autant
une vérité désormais jean marie le pen
attaquera systématiquement en
diffamation quiconque l'accusera d'avoir
commis des tortures
il faut dire que le président du front
national a le vent en poupe et se voit
un avenir politique considérable
le 17 juin 1984 il est élu député
européen
c'est un coup de tonnerre dans le
paysage politique français et le pen est
accueilli à strasbourg sous les huées de
ses collègues
le canard enchaîné publie alors un
éditorial à la une un émule de barbie
va-t-il entrer à l'assemblée européenne
à cette époque là le pen est à la
recherche d'un certain respectabilité il
n'est plus le le guerrier lesoudard fier
de ses de ses exploits discutable et il
veut montrer qu'il est un homme
politique respectable alors ça lui plaît
pas du tout dedans tendre seriné cette
histoire et donc il dit que c'est pas il
fait très rapidement à communiquer et à
notre grande surprise il dit c'est
absolument faux c'est je suis gravement
diffamé et d'ailleurs je fais un procès
aux canards alors il faut reprendre à
l'époque c'est c'est une surprise pour
nous parce que on pensait plutôt que ils
diraient oui et alors j'ai j'ai fait mon
devoir de soldat comme il l'avait répété
nombreuses reprises est pas du tout là
il dit c'est faux je vous fais un procès
c'est de la diffamation
le journal libération enquête lui aussi
sur le passé algérienne jean marie le
pen
le dossier qui paraît en 1985 fait
l'effet d'une bombe
cinq témoins algériens ils racontent
comment ils ont été torturés par jean
marie le pen
on y découvre le visage d'abdennour
yahiaoui l'homme du rapport gilles est
aussi le couteau retrouvé par mohamed
moulay
près de trente ans après les faits c'est
la première fois que des témoins
algériens parlent ouvertement
il décide de me parler je pense
je pense parce que j'arrive seul et que
je leur explique que je leur explique
jean marie le pen dont ils se
souviennent bien
va être candidat à la présidence de la
république en france
que je fais partie des gens
qui trouve ça insupportable
et que la seule façon peut-être
d'empêcher un tel homme
de se répandre à la télévision à la
radio et d'aller peut-être jusqu'à la
présidence
c'est dad c'est qu'ils témoignent eux
c'est qu'ils disent c'est qu'ils disent
vraiment qui est cet homme est parce qu
en fait qui a qu'eux qui possède une
vérité
capable de révéler le pen sous un jour
insupportable le pen
57,84 la question sont ce titre le
quotidien libération de ce matin publie
un dossier qui déjà fait l'effet d'un
brûlot inde aussi jean-marie le pen
attaque libération diffamation comme le
canard enchaîné est invité à réagir aux
accusations dont il fait l'objet il
ressort son discours sur la nécessité de
la torture pendant la guerre d'algérie
jeudi qu'il y avait des hommes qui
détenaient des réseaux bombe n'est ce
pas qu'ils détenaient des bombes et qui
tuer aveuglément des hommes et des
femmes l'armée française a été chargé
alors que ce n'était pas son travail
c'est un travail de police de faire
échec à cette offensive terroriste qui a
fait des dizaines de morts civils à
alger quels que soient les moyens je
pense que dans la guerre est ce que vous
connaissez une limite des moyens
les bombes les bayonnais qd les gaz tout
ce qui a été employé dans les conflits
prédit seules les victimes soient les
mains attachées offerte au couteau du
boucher monsieur le pen la loi
d'aministie lgv est oublié les faits qui
se sont produits en algérie à chaque
fois vous parlez de diffamation est ce
que pour autant ça vous distance de
prouver que vous n'avez jamais torture
en algérie mais écoutez moi je fais je
ne suis pas c'est pas moi de prouver que
j'ai jamais tentures et se sautera aux
gens qui au mépris de la loi d'ailleurs
devrait avoir à le prouver qu'un monde
ce pas encore dieu merci en système
soviétique
dans le monde un témoignage issu de
l'armée vient s'ajouter à ceux des
victimes algériennes
jean-maurice de marquer engagé avec le
pen en algérie et accuse son ancien ami
d'avoir torturé
le pen a fait partie lui même des
équipes qui torturaient personnellement
personnellement
[Musique]
dans la foulée le journal libération
publie le témoignage d'un ancien
légionnaire en poste à alger au même
moment que jean marie le pen
valser son nom il confirme qu'il a vu le
pen torturé
il tapait sur un type qui était déjà
bien entamée et encore branché à la
gégène
inventeur
jocistes à faux témoins mais comme il en
existe donc bien vous nous avez fait ça
et demandez-lui 7 qui n'a reçu cinquante
mille balles pour le faire il est mort
alors n'hesitez pas son exemple ne
s'était pas son témoignage
le plus manqué pendant toutes ces années
non mais bien sûr si vous faites la
collation si vous faites la collation de
tous les deux tout les diffamations dont
j'ai été l'objet vous en remplir et des
volumes entiers vous savez il n'y a pas
que lui et se valent ne faisait pas
partie de mon unité ait jamais entendu
parler de ce type autrement que danser
dans les journaux par ces accusations
voilà je pense que c'est très facile à
obtenir ce genre de faux témoignages
valmeux téléphone un jour à libération
ça a été un coup de téléphone très
surréaliste
il me dit je sais que vous travaillez
sur la guerre d'algérie
j'étais chercheur je m'appelle val
j'habite en hollande et si vous voulez
voir ma photo prenez les mémoires du
général massu à la page temps c'est moi
qui suis debout avec une mitraillette
derrière yassef saadi qui vient de se
faire arrêter et il me dit j'aimerais
vous rencontrer et il me raconte une
histoire
extrêmement intéressante quoi il me
raconte qui connaît toute cette période
tout ce qui c'est sûr le pen
sur la ville là où tout ça se passait
sur le climat en algérie et il dit si
vous avez un problème je viendrai
témoigner devant la justice française
vale viendra déposer sous serment devant
la justice française tout comme les
témoins algérien
mais jean marie le pen va gagner ses
procès contre le canard enchaîné autres
libérations et aussi contre son ancien
ami jean maurice de marc l
par trois fois le tribunal reconnaît la
diffamation
nous pouvions prouvé que nous avions
fait une enquête nous pouvions prouver
notre bonne foi mais nous aurions dû
disait le tribunal et la cour est plus
prudent dans notre expression et que
dans ces conditions là nous n'aurions
pas dû affirmer de façon absolument
certaine ce qui n'était pas absolument
certains ronds voilà en ce qui s'est
passé et nous nous sommes trouvés dans
cette situation incroyable d'être
condamné pour un homme qui niait avoir
fait les faits mais qu'il est
revendiquée sur le plan moral est ce que
ces deux procès du canard et de libé ont
donc fait taire ceux qui avaient
peut-être envie de parler de le pen et
de la torture c'est difficile de le
savoir ce que je sais en tout cas c'est
que ce n'a pas été un élément
fondamental du discours politique
pendant les années qui ont suivi
donc on peut penser que l'on peut penser
on peut penser que ce procès a réduit
sans doute d'une certaine façon la
liberté d'expression à ce sujet et il
n'y a plus jamais eu un numéro spécial
comme le numéro spécial que libération
avait fait sous la conduite de lionel
duroy y en a plus l'autre et il n'y a
pas d'autres organes de presse qui est
consacrée à ce sujet autant de place que
l'on avait consacré libération
jean-marie le pen continue son ascension
politique
en 1986 il retrouve son siège de député
à l'assemblée nationale
mais personne ne lui parle plus de
torture de peur d'être condamné pour
diffamation
en 1988 il est de nouveau candidat à la
présidentielle
on ne lui en parlera pas non plus sous
[Musique]
il faudra attendre 1992 pour que soit
brisée au détour d'une phrase la loi du
silence monsieur le pen il faut tout de
même savoir qui sait et s'en souvenir on
parle toujours sans mémoire il se trouve
que je suis le premier homme à l'avoir
traîné devant un tribunal on fait
condamné pour fraude électorale front
des lecteurs ou à l'usure élections
professionnelles d'étudiants c'était en
1952 il est ensuite allé en algérie il a
torturé il est milliardaire le pen
attaque rocard en diffamation bien sûr
comme il vient d'attaquer pierre vidal
naquet le grand historien qui dans ses
mémoires rappelle qu'il a publié dès
1962 le rapport gilles qui accuse le pen
d'être un tortionnaire
mais pour la première fois le pen va
perdre il va perdre les deux procès
c'est un spectaculaire retournement de
jurisprudence
moi quand j'ai plaidé pour des dalles
naquet je n'ai sorti aucun document
inédit tous les documents dont j'ai fait
état étaient connus depuis longtemps il
avait déjà été utilisé par mes confrères
dans les artères précédente celle
concernant le canard enchaîné libération
etc mais à l'époque n'avait pas eu le
même impact parce qu'on était vingt ans
plus tard et que les choses avaient mûri
qu'une certaine distance avait été prise
avec la guerre d'algérie que le débat se
développer et que nous avons même eu le
général massu qui lui avait revendiqué
la pratique de la torture par la guerre
d'algérie qui au soir de sa vie à 93 94
ans a dit non ça n'était pas nécessaire
donc les esprits avait muré les esprits
avaient changé et c'est pourquoi les
pièces que j'ai produites qui encore une
fois n'avait rien de sensationnel et de
nouveau en tout cas on est élu examiné
différemment
voici notre estimation du résultat du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en tête jacques chirac
20% des voix énorme surprise jean marie
le pen semble devoir être le ferons avec
17% des voix arrive 2002 et le séisme du
premier tour de la présidentielle à
alger c'est la stupéfaction
alors d'autres langues se délient le
journal le monde publie de nouveaux
témoignages d'algériens qui racontent
des séances de torture avec le président
du front national
ce sont eux qui parlent dans ce film
pour la journaliste du monde aucun doute
sur la véracité de ces récits
ça a été si vous voulez une conclusion
qui s'établit très très lentement et
j'avais un souci d'autant plus grand
comment vous dire d'être sûr que je me
trompais pas que je me faisais c'est
trop facile de taper comme ça sur jean
marie le pen sous prétexte que c'est le
leader du front national et tout donc je
crois que j ai mis un scrupule d'autant
plus grand de coupe et recouper il ya
plein de témoins que j'ai été voir qui
ne figure pas dans les papiers du monde
que j'ai écrit mais qui figure en
revanche dans mon livre et qui eux sont
des témoins extérieurs qui m'ont servi
ensuite pour les procès
car jean marie le pen oppose un démenti
formel aux accusations du monde et bien
sûr attaque le journal en diffamation
il s'est défendu ils avaient peut être
un avocat qui était tout à fait pu glace
il a fait venir ses supérieurs de ses
supérieurs hiérarchiques
lorsqu'il était lieutenant algérie
il a produit des documents il a
argumenté pour dire qu'il était
impossible qu' il est plus torturé parce
que
parce que il appartenait à une unité qui
davet un secteur géographique qui était
différent de celui dans lequel avait été
pratiqué la torture évoqués par les
témoins que nous faisions produire et
qui s'était exprimé dans le monde et
bien qu'il se soit défendu et défendu de
façon tout à fait efficace malgré son
absence eh bien il a perdu et le
tribunal a dit que tous les éléments de
la bonne foi se trouvaient réunis
la justice reconnaît la bonne foi de la
journaliste du monde c'est à dire le
sérieux et la partialité de son enquête
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour le pen
pour la troisième fois consécutive il
est débouté de ses poursuites
ensuite alors on passa aux années 2000
et à la aux années 2000 vous commencez à
perdre des procès vous perdez attendez
laissez moi finir vous perdez rien dit
vous perdez contre vidal naquet vous
perdez contrecarre et vous perdez contre
le monde expliquez moi ça je ne perds
pas c'est à dire que il leur est
reconnue ce que je trouve abusif moi
d'ailleurs la bonne foi on ne dit pas
que les imputations qu'ils portent sont
vraies mais on dit qu'ils sont de bonne
foi voilà donc chacun pour être de bonne
foi faut être de gauche dire alors sont
de bonne foi ils apprennent le monde
peut pas être de mauvaise foi il est
forcément de bonne foi donc voilà c'est
tout mais ça ne prouve pas contre moi ça
ça prouve simplement le laxisme de la
part de la justice française
l'appréciation
libéral quand il s'agit de mes
adversaires contre le pen tout est
permis
c'est un homme seul fayda ses amis mais
autrement
un homme seul il n'est lié à aucune des
grandes puissances de la république dit
social économique et syndical
nini financière
1,10 médiatique c'est un type avec qui
on peut y aller quoi somme toute
le pen serait donc la malheureuse
victime d'une justice partiale et selon
lui toutes les accusations qui se
succèdent depuis 50 ans aurait un but
précis
n'oublions pas une chose c'est le
gouvernement de l'algérie depuis cette
période de 62 c'est un gouvernement
effet l'aisne c'est un gouvernement qui
a key qui estime qu'il doit se donner
des moyens diplomatiques et politiques
de discuter ou avec la france et qui
essaye de mettre des cartes de son côté
ce sont des actions de propagande et des
actions de propagande dans une guerre
révolutionnaire
quoi de plus banal et bien évidemment
mais fall est finie la guerre là c'est
depuis longtemps non mais il ya l'état
algérien vous le savez à des rapports le
moins qu'on puisse dire
douloureux avec la métropole française
et ils essayent d'obtenir des
concessions il essaye de jouer sur le
sentiment de culpabilité or moi je n'ai
aucun sentiment de culpabilité
je le dis très clairement moi je n'ai
fait que mon devoir j'ai fait mon devoir
et paix je n'ai pas du tout à ma maman
justifier le pen a fait des dégâts non
seulement il va tenter des jambes mais
il n'a aidé à me violer enfin violet on
recense
dans l'intégrité
dans l'oeil vissé sais c'est que c'est
une éruption dans la vie de certains
clichés d'une violence telle que on ne
peut pas oublier le pen comme ça c tu as
déjà qu'ils sont traumatisés à l'huile
vraiment je suis souffert moralement
et physiquement bon surtout moralement
jusqu'à maintenant 50 ans je pas dormi
cieux je posais des
devoirs
mon coeur est et
s'auto pour que mes camarades
on a été des résistants
il a par le roi jean marie pelt de le
faire ça il lui pardonnerai jamais la
paix le pardon exemple
l'impossible
maman c'est un type aig qu'il devait pas
être candidate si le bon 10 à plusieurs
lie
terminal international
chinois qui devait n'être pas
candidat à la présidence
jean marie le pen devant un tribunal qui
jugera les faits sur le fond qui
établirait enfin ce qui est vrai ou non
cela n'arrivera jamais l'amnistié rend
impossible toute démarche en ce sens
le pen ne pourra jamais prouver une
bonne fois pour toute son innocence
les algériens qui l'accusent de torture
eux ne pourront jamais voir leurs
paroles reconnu et obtenir réparation
pour la justice le dossier est clos
définitivement
[Musique]
reste le travail des journalistes et des
historiens pour tenter d'établir ce qui
s'est vraiment passé il ya 50 ans dans
les centres de torture d'alger est
derrière les lourdes portes des maisons
de la casbah
[Musique]